[Musik]
das podcast ist broadbent munich ist
vielleicht sogar offensichtlich ein
interessantes thema für uns für uns alle
und vielleicht muss ich sie nicht
überreden dass es interessant ist weil
sonst wären sie nicht hier weil sie
natürlich schon gesehen haben dass die
vorlesung sich damit beschäftigt
allerdings wollte ich heute noch nicht
die geschichte der flüsse wie der tiere
treffen sondern das allgemeine die
allgemeine problematik zu sagen
und vielleicht werde ich ganz am ende
des semesters zurückkommen wollen weil
wir in der letzten sitzung dieses sehen
können
mozilla riss muss besprechen werden und
das ist vielleicht die prägendste
tradition in der jetzigen tierethik zum
beispiel ist gibt es einen philosoph den
ich auch heute kurz erwähnen werde
peter singer der us jurist ist und der
sehr prominent ist unter den philosophen
die tierethik dann betreiben so sagen
ich werde auch heute am ende was zu der
frage sagen wieso wir dieses thema
innerhalb der geschichte der philosophie
betrachten wollen oder warum ich das so
betrachten will ich will aber natürlich
nichts zu verneinen dass man durchaus
eine interessante vorlesungen serie nur
zur jetzigen tiere geben könnte oder
auch philosophie des geistes
hinsichtlich der fragt die fragen wie
tiere mit uns vergleichbar sind wie ich
heute auch kurz besprechen werde
der grund wofür ich das historisch
betrachtet ist eigentlich weil ich
plötzlich historiker wenn also dass das
ist eher das was ich zu ihrem thema
bringen kann und wie ich am heute am
ende sagen werde
hoffe ich dass es auch
die beleuchtet ist diese fragen aus der
perspektive der früheren phasen der
geschichte wie zu betrachten
ok floss wie der tiere reagieren
hier haben wir meines erachtens mit zwei
großen bereichen der philosophie zu tun
nämlich aytac beziehungsweise vielleicht
politische persönlich vielleicht könnte
man praktische theologie sagen habe
kurzum ethik und philosophie des geistes
das heißt grundsätzlich kann man zwei
arten von fragen zu stellen nämlich wie
sollen wir mit tieren ethisch gesehen
umgehen
zum beispiel auf offensichtliche frage
dürfen wir die ersten dürfen wir sie für
experimente herr nehmen und so weiter
also eine art von frage so seien die
eine derart von frage hat mit
philosophie des geistes zu tun
und hier geht es darum die frage zu
beantworten wie die tiere sozusagen
mental funktionieren
zum beispiel ob sie denken können ob sie
erlebnisse haben genau wie so wie wir
sie haben und so weiter
also zuerst so der so der ethischen
seite der frage die also wenn man diese
ethische fragen stellt kommt man
vielleicht zuerst auf fragen die mit
unserer mit unseren uns unserer
verantwortung als einzelne bürger oder
personen zu tun haben
wie schon gesagt ob wir sie essen dürfen
ob wir zum beispiel jagen dürfen ob es
zulässig es zum beispiel zum tierpark zu
gehen und im allgemeinen ob wir in
einzelnen ebenso zu sagen richtig leben
hinsichtlich diese andere lebewesen mit
wenn wir unser planet halten
wir haben über nachgedacht ich könnte es
schon öffentlich fragen welcher
vegetarier ist und werden nicht aber ich
glaube ich dass ich das nicht mache warf
als dass es leute gibt die das nicht
äußern wollen
aber ich wollte trotzdem sagen ich habe
auch gedacht ich könnte für amerikanisch
wer ist vegetarier
wer ist jemals ein tierpark gegangen wer
hat jemals als ein mittel zu sich
genommen die mit ihren produkten
experimente produziert würde und das
gilt für uns wahrscheinlich alle oder
und so weiter und so fort
also wenn man also wenn man diese
ethische fragen überlegt dort kommt man
sehr schnell zu dem schluss dass selbst
die veganer unter uns irgendwie ethische
probleme haben die mit tieren zu tun
haben
selbst wenn zum beispiel selbst wenn man
betrachtet was was ist impliziert nur
sich nur von gemüse getreide und so
weiter so zu ernähren ist es
offensichtlich dass tiere auch unter der
industrie des essens produkt dessen
produktion leiden zb werden zahlreiche
insekten umgebracht um getreide zu
ernten oder gift wird eingesetzt damit
ihr obst erfolgreich an pflanzen können
und so weiter und so fort
ich gehe davon aus dass niemand hier
irgendwie im urwald lebt und nur von dem
eigenen garten gemein sie sind sie sind
alle hier
ja sagt dass sie an der uni sind heißt
das sie mit öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
ist bleibt gekommen sind und selbst das
hat die tiere beeinflusst also niemand
es hier so sagen
völlig unschuldig allerdings sind manche
von unschuldiger als andere
und die frage ist vielleicht wäre wer
ist an nächsten richtig zu leben und das
sind glaube ich die offensichtlichen
fragen die materie zu tun haben die
philosophischen und das sind fragen die
plötzlich jeder jede person die ein
bisschen nachdenkt schon überlegt hat
ich würde sogar sagen dass das die
philosophische fragen gehört die am
häufigsten von nicht philosophen
gestellt werden
beim 1 du kannst nichts in die straße
gehen eine beliebige person aussuchen
und ihn fragen was ist deine haltung zu
dass das problem der personale identität
oder bist du interna liszt oder externer
lässt in der psychologie oder was ist
deine kräfte modellierung der modal
logik wir könnten das versuchen aber
verkehren aber das würde ich nicht
unbedingt vorschlagen aber du kannst
praktisch jeder person sagen was ist
deine meinung so tätig und sie werden
sofort meine meinung haben oder
mindestens zu geben dass sie das
überlebt haben und oft würden sie
wahrscheinlich zu geben dass sie nicht
ganz so leben wie sie es eigentlich für
richtig halten würden ja also das ist
die die ethische seite der frage auf den
herd dem niveau der einzelperson
allerdings gibt es auch hier und das ist
vielleicht sogar wichtiger eine
politische dimension weil wir als
einzelpersonen offensichtlich relativ
wenig einfluss haben auf phänomene wie
die industrie oder die erst der umwelt
geht was natürlich tiere beeinflusst und
so weiter also da haben wir vielleicht
mehr mit fragen der politischen klasse
sie zu tun wobei man hier auch sehr
praktisch denken kann zb
soll ich die interessen der tiere
betrachten wenn ich mich entscheide wie
ich welche partei ich wähle sollte das
überhaupt betrachten und wenn schon ist
das vielleicht das wichtigste thema das
ich betragen soll
ist das relativ unwichtig und so weiter
und so fort
finde so fischer gesehen könnte man auch
fragen welche politische strukturen
sollen wir einführen um sicherzustellen
dass menschen oder vielleicht zum
menschen in deutschland oder in unserem
land richtig mit tieren umgehen sehr
grob die die praktische seite der frage
sehr grob die andere seite der frage
philosophie des geistes hier haben wir
eher damit zu tun mit der frage ob tiere
oder inwiefern tiere so was wie ein
mentales leben haben so haben sie zum
beispiel bewusstsein haben sie
erfahrungen genau wie wir können sie zum
beispiel schmerzempfinden wenn dann
empfinden schmerz genauso wie wir und so
weiter und so fort
natürlich ist es nicht der fall dass
diese zwei arten von philosophischen
fragen da voneinander unabhängig sind
zum beispiel wenn man touristisch denkt
könnte man vielleicht meinen dass es
sehr sehr entscheidend ist inwiefern
tiere schmerzempfinden können zum
beispiel wenn man sich überzeugt dass
fische kein schmerzempfinden würde man
vielleicht als tülle teil ist sagen okay
dann ist es egal ob man einen fisch
quält aber wenn fische doch
schmerzempfinden können dann ist es
ethisch unannehmbar fische zu können
oder zu fangen oder zu essen usw
ich würde sogar sagen dass es eine
allgemeine annahme in der geschichte
philosophie ist
dass unsere oder dass die richtige
ethische behandlung und hirn davon
abhängig ist was wir über die tiere
hinsichtlich des wie des geistes sagen
zum beispiel wenn wir zugeben dass tiere
nicht denken können oder nicht rationell
sind würden manche philosophen wie wir
sein werden sofort davon entnehmen dass
sie überhaupt keinen kritischen wert
haben zum beispiel die historiker oder
auch kant würden praktisch unmittelbar
aus der nichts nationalität wörtchen
erschließen dass wir überhaupt keine
ethische ethische fragen zu tieren
standen müssen die sind praktisch genau
wie steine und stöcke für uns weiß
internationale national handelnde
personen sind sozusagen also diese diese
zwei seiten der frage sind durchaus
miteinander verbunden und ich würde
vielleicht auch vorsichtig sagen dass
obwohl ich heute zuerst tiefer in die
ethische fragen eingehen werde
ich würde eher sagen dass die fragen zur
philosophie des geistes grundlegender
sind weil zum beispiel nehmen wir an
dass descartes recht hatte der kreis
sieht das neue wertigkeit war und wir
werden eine sitzung haben sie werden
sehen dass er der meinung war das tier
der eigentlich nur organische
mechanismen sind sie haben kein mentales
leben
es ist sozusagen deutschen darüber die
raum es gibt kein geist in einem tier
und das würde heißen dass sie überhaupt
keine erfahrungen haben sie können haut
nicht schmerzempfinden
vielleicht tun sie so als ob sie ein
mentales neben haben aber das ist
irgendwie irre führt
also diese diese phänomene die wir sehen
zb dass ein tier so rum wird wenn man
dem tier wehtut
das ist nur ein nachahmung schaut aus
wie schmerz empfinden ist aber nichts
wenn das der fall ist hat diese hat
diese tatsache erhebliche ethische
konsequenzen nämlich mehr oder weniger
wir können genau das mit tieren machen
was wir wollen
weil die am sowieso sie können das
sowieso nichts erfahren was wir machen
also als alles alles egal
das ist natürlich ein extrem war von dem
allgemeinen punkt aber der allgemeine
punkt bleibt bestehen das heißt wir
sollen wahrscheinlich philosophisch
gesehen methodisch gesehen
zuerst feststellen was wir über diese
fragen zur philosophie des geistes sagen
sollten und dann anhand der antwort
können wir eine ethische ästhetische
theorie oder eine theorie der tätig
darauf bauen
immerhin würde ich aber auch sagen dass
man nicht unbedingt sozusagen eine
vollständige theorie über geist über
über das geist der tieren haben um die
ethische fragen zu beantworten je
nachdem welche ethische theorie man
bevorzugt zum beispiel noch mal um
rutelli tourismus zu benennen
wenn man diese auffassung ist dass man
als jurist nur schmerz vermeiden will
und lust maximieren dann ist die einzige
frage die wir beantworten müssen
eigentlich habt ihr schmerzempfinden
können oder und lustempfinden können
oder nicht und wenn die antwort ja ist
dann ist das doch so sein wir müssen
nicht überlegen ok können sie denken
können sie kleine schaffen und so weiter
und so fort
also die die die voraussetzung tätig
erfolgreich zu machen hat ein bisschen
damit zu tun
welche art von tätig man betreiben will
aber eben allgemeine würde ich trotzdem
sagen dass wir so sagen wir zwei
schritte haben nämlich ein schritt zur
philosophie des geistes und dann ein
schritt zur ethik beziehungsweise
politische größe die erste allgemeine
bemerkung ja ich habe bisher immer
einfach tiere gesagt und hier
und das werde ich auch weiter so machen
aber erstens nur um klar zu sein ich es
mir bewusst dass menschen tiere sind und
natürlich in der antiken und
mittelalterlichen straßen auch später
war es sogar typisch nach aristoteles
mensch als nationales tier zu definieren
also diesen anhalten und philosophen
sehr bewusst dass menschen auch tiere
sind und von daher ist ein bisschen
vielleicht ein bisschen irre führen wenn
ich ständig tiere der tiere sage ich
hätte eigentlich die ganze zeit
nichtmenschliche tiere immer sagen
sollen
aber das wäre etwas ärgerlich und
ungünstig also ich hab jetzt oder
sozusagen als sogar seit anfang dieser
sitzung wenn ich hier sage das heißt
nichts menschliches nicht menschlich ist
ihr haus so dass ich das anders dann
formuliert ist zum beispiel wenn ich
sage mensch ist ein tier das heißt
nichts mensch ist ein nicht menschliches
hier hoffen sie
weil ich mich ungern widerlege und auch
und wollte ich dazu sagen und das tier
ein sehr allgemeines wird ist und deckt
eigentlich alle lebewesen ab die keine
menschen sind und keine pflanzen und wir
werden auch erwähnt des semesters sehen
das ist ein dass es überhaupt nicht
offensichtlich ist dass diese gattung
hier eine einheitliche gattung ist man
könnt ihr das bestreiten man könnte
sagen es gibt nichts menschen tiere und
pflanzen es gibt vielleicht menschen
vögel landtiere und wassertiere und dann
pflanzen oder es gibt menschen tiere mit
zwei oder vielleicht gar nicht menschen
es gibt tiere mit zwei beinen
mit vier beinen tiere mit keinen beinen
pflanzen oder so man kann es so zu sagen
so außen hin wie man will und es ist
eine offene philosophische frage wie man
am besten man das am besten macht und es
ist eine offene frage ob man pauschal
irgend etwas nützliches auf der
physischen ebene zu alle tiere sagen
kann
ich würde das sogar vielleicht sogar
vielleicht indessen skeptisch zum
beispiel wenn wir ethische fragen
betrachten es ist sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich glaube ich dass das was
wir einem affen ethisch schulden genau
das ist was für einem turm schulden
betrachten sie zum beispiel die frage an
sie haben einen affen vor sich und einen
wurm und ich habe eine pistole und
bedrohte sie und sage ich werde sie
erschießen wenn sie nicht eins von
diesen zwei tieren umbringen da hätten
sie drei möglichkeiten sie können sagen
ich bringe kein tier und erschießt mich
sie können sagen ich bringe den rachen
oder ich bringe das den börsen könnte
natürlich sagen ich bin beides war es
aber nehmen wir an sie werden zwischen
diesen drei
ich glaube es ist sehr offensichtlich
das ist die falsche antwort ist die nach
uns umzubringen
und das ist vielleicht sogar ein
kontrovers würde jemand den hafen
umbringen hat jemand hier war es gegen
affen
ok also jeder kann sagen jeder der eins
und dem zwei tieren umbringen würde
würde den dem sektor entwurmung bringen
anstatt einen hafen manche philosophen
würden wahrscheinlich sagen erschießt
mich dann zum beispiel die gunners in
der indischen tradition würden das sagen
wenn es sind die ganz ernsthafte chinas
aber selbst das ist sehr selten
diese einstellung und ich glaube
wahrscheinlich würde jeder von uns
sofort sagen die richtige antwort ist
form bringen und dass dieses
gedankenexperiment sykes glaube ich
sofort das ist nicht der fall ist dass
alle tiere gleich dass die den gleichen
wert haben
sie sind verschieden und das gilt auch
natürlich für philosophie des geistes
also wenn ich frage wo zum beispiel
können tiere denken das ist durchaus
sinnvolles zu sagen so was wie affen ja
insekten nein und vielleicht können wir
so können wir uns sogar vorstellen es
gibt es keine rangordnung von tieren von
person ganz basic tiere die was er wie
pflanzen sind also bieten wie man auf
dem meer hat das affen und delfine also
weiter ganz oben
schlaue tiere
runde und ist es intuitiv und
wahrscheinlich auch nicht falsch das zu
glauben dass die dass manche tiere
irgendwie beeindruckender sense und
paaren komplexe sense und ein und ein
mentales leben haben was näher zu
menschen das menschliche leben haben als
andere tiere
das ist glaube ich intuitiv und wird von
unseren versoffenen der geschichte wo
sie eigentlich nie infrage gestellt also
das heißt vielleicht wenn wir die frage
formulieren zum beispiel wie sollen wir
tiere behandeln
vielleicht könnte man das so auslegen
dass wir hier fragen wie sollen wir die
atmung von tiere behandeln die
irgendwelche bestimmte eigenschaften
haben wodurch sie wehrte dann verdienen
zum beispiel
wir stellen die frage ob es überhaupt
tiere gibt die wir gut behandeln müssen
oder wenn wir zum beispiel fragen und
glaube das ist auch etwas was wir
normalerweise meinen wenn wir sagen wenn
wir fragen ob wir tiere essen dürfen
normalerweise was wird damit meinen ist
nichts dürfen wir insekten essen sondern
dort gibt es überhaupt irgendwelche
tiere die wir essen dürfen
es ist meiner meinung nach nicht
auszuschließen dass ein werk geteilt ein
vegetarier sagen könnte ja natürlich
erst sich insekten weil das ist egal
also das sind ethisch nicht bedeutsam
aber kühe und schafe und hühner so auf
keinen fall
vielleicht könnte man sogar sagen
ich esse insekten und fische aber keine
landtiere es gibt sogar diese gattung
von vegetarier die heißen pass gitarre
glaub ich hatte gehört dass vegetarier
auf englisch nennen diese leute fashion
chats oder also das sind die sind
vegetarier die fisch essen und das ist
vielleicht einfach weil sie denken dass
alle daten und fleisch ungesund sind
aber angenommen sie machen das aus
ethischen gründen werde die überlegung
ja für sie fische sind nicht so
fortgeschritten wie kühl und so weiter
deswegen bin ich bereit für schießen wo
ich das an einer kühl nicht antun würde
okay das waren meine allgemeine
überlegungen zum thema vielleicht mag
ich schon da eine kurze pause hat
niemanden fragen oder beobachtungen
bevor wir bevor es ernsthafte wird jetzt
die ethische seite der frage
hier wäre ein guter erster schritt
meiner meinung nach die folgende frage
zu stellen
die erstaunlicherweise so weit wie sehen
kann sehr wenig gestellt wird mindestens
in der öffentlichen diskurs zu sortieren
nämlich dann wenn wenn es hier darum
geht dass zu debattieren ob die wir
tiere behandeln gut behandeln sollen
oder vielleicht könnte man sagen ob und
inwiefern wird hier besser behandeln
sollen wie wir das jetzt tun
ich glaube dass das ist allgemein
gängiges dass die was man sagen
vielleicht was man beweislast nennen
könnte dass sie auf der seite der des
verteidigers der tieren liegt also das
heißt wir haben sozusagen ein status quo
die wir jetzt mit tieren umgehen und die
idee werde anscheinend wenn wir handels
vorgehen sollen
dann muss derjenige der das ändern will
das beweisen oder für das häufig
begründen und wenn kein für sorbische
argumente dafür geliefert wird dann ist
es so sagen beide fort das ergebnis das
wir einfach so weitermachen wie wir
jetzt machen und das ist meiner meinung
nach ein bisschen seltsam als zu seinen
gründen regelungen für die ganze debatte
also erstens ist es mir nicht ganz klar
warum wir im allgemeinen die jetzige
sitten in eine gesellschaft als
grundlegende basis für eine
philosophische debatte haben sollten zum
beispiel nehmen wir an wir sind im
siebzehnten und achtzehnten jahrhunderts
dann würden wir sagen müssen dass die
beweislast für das thema der sklaverei
auf denjenigen lied der sklaverei
verbannen will
und für mich ist intuitiv zu sagen dass
die beweislast damals was auch immer
wirklich stattgefunden hat in der
debatte die beweislast lag eigentlich an
die leute die die rechts haben wollten
haben die den menschen als sklaven zu
kaufen und zu verkaufen würde ich mal
sagen
außerdem für das grafisch gesehen ich
habe ein motto was ich auch gern kraft
gern einsätze der philosophie ist es
egal welche zeit es ist so wie das in
kelheim ist also das heißt die die
tatsache dass wir jetzt in 2009 10 noch
leben ist philosophisch gesehen egal
und die tatsache dass wir in europa
leben ist auch philosophisch gesehen
egal dass es zufall und unsere intuition
und sitten
die wir ethische leben im allgemeinen
und wie wir ethisch mit ihren tieren
umgehen das ist alles nur zufall
dadurch dass wir hier und jetzt leben
und nichts anderes war ein anderes waren
vielleicht könnte man argumentieren dass
es im allgemeinen keine gute eine gute
praxis ist die sitten der jetzigen
gesellschaft als basis zu nehmen hat
also das disco als precious susan eine
richtlinie zu nehmen für ethische
debatten einfach aus praktischen gründen
aber philosophisch gesehen sind so viele
gründe dass zu machen
und außerdem wenn es wenn es hier um
ethik geht könnte man sagen was wäre
wenn die ethische debatte über tiere ist
schwer zu entscheiden ist was es zum
beispiel wenn es gute argumente beiden
seiten gibt und diese mehr oder weniger
gleichgültig oder gleich überzeugend
dann würde ich sagen oder vorschlagen
mindestens dass es vielleicht
schlüssiges zu denken dass wir jede gut
behandeln sollen oder so gut wie möglich
einfach weil wir auf nummer sicher gehen
sollen
dabei wäre es zum beispiel wenn die
frage ist sollen wir tiere essen und wir
sehen gute argumente dafür und dagegen
also wenn ja wenn wir alle argumente
nehmen und es ist mehr oder weniger im
gleichgewicht
sozusagen dann könnte man vielleicht
überlegen ja dann sollte keine tiere
essen nur falls es falsch ist weil es
mir lieber ist mir wichtiger hätte die
ethisch nichts an nimmt man im bade
handlung zu vermeiden als tiere zu
lassen
ja
der punkt dieser vorlesung ist nichts
sie alle zu überzeugen dass sie
vegetarisch leben sollen
das nehme ich nur als philosophische
überlegungen ja also kurzum was ich
sagen will ist dass ich es ich sehe
jetzt eine schwäche der jetzigen tätig
debatte vielleicht sogar innerhalb der
philosophie das nie gesagt die argumente
argumentation last käme auf die
verteidiger der tierethik liegt und
nicht auf diejenigen die verteidigen
müssen dass wir so tun wie wir es jetzt
schon im allgemeinen der gesellschaft
tun also intuitiv ist dass wir
mindestens nicht klar wie sollte die
last auf dieser seite liegen soll
allerdings ist es vielleicht nichts
überraschend dass es so ist aus mehreren
gründen erstens dieses ganze phänomen
das ist professionelle philosophen gibt
die sich vorwiegend oder oft mit
thematik beschäftigen das ist eigentlich
ein neues phänomen in meinen in denen
von sie gern zum beispiel glaube ich
nicht dass sie an einer hässlichen uni
vorlesungen oder seminare sortierte
gefunden hätten
wenn dann nur sehr sparsam wenn man das
jetzt was an jeder uni irgendwo finden
kann
es gibt dutzende wenn nicht hunderte
gute flüsse die bücher zu dem zu dieser
frage der theoretiker und das ist
wirklich ein
es ist wirklich ein hauptthema in der
philosophie geworden
und das heißt dass philosophen als
susanne gesellschaftskritiker in diese
debatte eingestiegen sind seit mehr oder
weniger den 1906 siegern und von daher
ist es nicht über nicht überraschend
dass es mindestens 1
dass die argumentation ist last wird es
häufig gesehen auf dem gesicht sagen
einfach immer verteidiger liegt weil sie
eben
sie wurden genau sagen dass die
gesellschaftliche normen womit wir tiere
jetzt behandeln falsch waren und das ist
immer noch der fall
und das heißt dass die meisten leute die
professionelle tierethik machen wollen
philosophie einsetzen um die
verteidigung der tiere oder um das der
behandlung der tiere stark zu machen
das ist übrigens dass das könnte
vielleicht pervers klingen aber ich
finde das ist auch eine schwäche dieser
literatur
weil wenn wenn wenn man eine gute für
eine solche debatte haben will ist
eigentlich hilfreich wenn beide seiten
der debatte auf höchstem niveau
kritisiert werden und hier haben wir
eher den fall das was alle diese orte
schreiben geben gründen warum wir tiere
besser behandeln sollen
und niemand will der star des cro
verteidigen und das ist das bett das
wäre ein das ist nicht so schlimm
es gibt schon leute die das machen aber
die große große mehrheit der philosophen
die tätig besprechen wollen dass wir
philosophisch zeigen dass tiere besser
behandelt werden sollten
das einzige was sie trennt ist wieso
also die haupt debatten in der tätig
sind nicht tiere besser behandeln oder
nichts die hauptarbeiten sind ja
natürlich die bessere hand aber warum
das das würde ich vorsichtig sehr
vorsichtig mit gender verlassen wie das
des handelns des senders
sowie des senders vergleichen da ist
auch ein fall wo fast alle philosophen
die sich für gender interessieren
sozusagen politisch links sind dass sie
die die debatten sind zum beispiel
zwischen sehr starke feministen und
trends leute die arterien über
transgender leute dann ausüben wollen
aber es gibt niemand es gibt was niemand
in der gender debatte die der zb die
ansichten der republikanische partei in
der wenigen staaten teilen bürger das
ist ausgeschlossen
das ist einfach offensichtlich mit
natürlich und philosophische bedeutung
und vielleicht ist das auch richtig aber
das heißt dass die genau wie in der tate
tätig ist die ganze debatte auf einer
seite einer anderen größeren debatte ok
andererseits wenn sie dafür sind dass
wir für das einsetzen und die rechte der
tiere zu verteidigen
bis das in ordnung weil die frage werde
dann nur wie unter diese dass das das
ziel ist dieser philosophischen
überlegung wird einfach geschenkt so
sagen
trotzdem werde ich an in ein paar
minuten was kurzes sagen wie man
vielleicht die haben die eine
philosophische begründung geben könnte
und das disco zu verteilen ok so
angenommen dass unser ziel erst für das
so philosophisch zu sagen warum wir mit
ihren fast sanfter und inseln als wir
das jetzt machen was könnte man machen
also was welche philosophische methoden
gibt es und das zu tun und hier würde
ich so allgemeinen beobachten
das ist vielleicht etwas eine
vereinfachung wie klappt es ist mehr
oder weniger richtige was die
theoretiker gemacht haben erst sie haben
alle die ethische theorien angeschaut
die es gibt und überlegt wie sie diese
theorien einsetzen könnten
zu diesem thema zum beispiel so
vielleicht nicht so viel nicht so sehr
ein neo ästhetische world wide webs das
kommt nicht so oft vor
das wäre vielleicht eine marktlücke wenn
ich immer das machen wollen würde aber
an sie nehmen inspiration aus der
kroatischen ethik haus utilitarismus und
aus der politischen philosophie denken
okay wie werden die rechte der menschen
oder die interessen der menschen dann
philosophisch erklärt und dann durch
transposition überlegen sie okay wie
könnt ihr genau diese methoden einsetzen
und ihre tierethik zu machen
man könnte fast sagen dass die ganze
branche
der hätte die wir tiere hätten benennen
ist nur eine angewandte fassung der
allgemeinen ethik also jede jede version
mehr ethische theorie kann man dann
vielleicht auf tiere in wänden und hier
ist das offensichtlichste beispiel
mozilla tourismus oder sozialismus und
die vorher gesagt habe ist hier der
prägende figur peter senger er ist ein
sehr starker und elitär ist
und das heißt dass es nach seiner
auffassung durch die gäste alle ethische
handlungen zu bewerten dass sie gut sind
wenn es sie die theorie also dass das
nützliche maximieren und das nicht
youtube also dass das nicht nützliche
minimieren
also sozusagen eine da muss man was
messen oder rechnen
welche folgen eine bestimmte handlung
oder besser handlungsort haben würde
und erst dann weiß man ob die
handlungsort zulässiges oder nichts
weiteres beispiel soll man üben
nein weil wenn alle lügen
er hat das grundsätzliche folgen
es wird dazu dass leute leiden sich
nicht gegenseitig trauen können
gesellschaft blickt da ist einander das
alles schlägt soll man leute umarmen ja
war das ganz anders
wir wollen alle um uns sein oder nicht
jetzt aber vielleicht nach der vorlesung
hat seine gründe
das wäre technisch gesehen sehr gut
wurde vielleicht sogar noch
offensichtlicher soll mann handelt der
leute hauen nein weil es weh tut und wer
ist das gegenteil von von nützlich habe
am anfang dieser koalition und das
werden wir auch später betrachten haben
ende des semesters ging jetzt wirklich
sehr gezielt auf lust und schmerz oder
lust und leiden also leiden war das
schlechte lustempfinden war das gute
alles was lust kann dann produziert ist
gut alles was leiden produziert schlägt
alles was bäder noch produziert ist
neutral
das ist sozusagen klassisches tourismus
wie wir das bei mehreren vor allem band
finden
natürlich gibt es mittlerweile iks viele
arten von materie aber sänger neigt dazu
so ein klassischer gitarrist zu sein
also was er wirklich machen will ist
dass das nützliche und das geht
eigentlich darum zu kalkulieren was die
interessen der lebewesen sind sind
hinsichtlich auf ihre erfahrung
vor allem ob sie schmerz oder lust zu
empfinden wir wollen wollen noch mal
dass sich maximieren
der schmerzliche minimieren und da ist
ja wirklich single ist dafür bekannt
dass er das ganz ganz extremen tut zum
beispiel glücklich dass er argumentiert
hat dass das neugeborene menschen die
vielleicht irgendwelche defekt haben
vielleicht weniger wert sind als
markieren was für manche leute empörend
ist aber er sollte also wenn das tier
husten schmerzen merken finden kann
heißt dieses baby dann sind die
interessen der ist er ist ihr wichtiger
heute mehr zu bewerten
es gibt probleme die man gegen
militarismus oder die sie rituell ist
die touristische herangehensweise dann
verwenden kann
erste kritik und meines erachtens eine
berechtigte kritik ist mit aris muss ist
falsch wäre natürlich ein eine längere
besprechung aber wenn man wenn man nicht
im allgemeinen bietet alles ist dann ist
diese modelle touristische begründung
für die ethik dann hinfällig
natürlich haben aber das zur seite es
gibt ein paar andere probleme die ein
bisschen schneller sind die fokussierte
ein problem erst das atelier im
allgemeinen natürlich bereits sind die
anscheinende in terrassen eines
lebewesens sozusagen zu opfern wenn man
dadurch ein größeres nutzen erreichen
kann
sie hat haben wir klassische beispiele
wie ich würde einen zug entgleisen und
wohl ich weiß dass dazu dann eine person
umbringen wird wenn
wenn ich das nicht mache das würde dann
fünf andere menschen und bringen oder
ein bisschen konkreter wir haben
jemanden festgenommen und er hat eine
bombe irgendwo in der stadt versteckt
jeweils dass die bande innerhalb stunden
dann explodieren wird
er weigert sich zu sagen wo die bombe
liegt dafür darf ich ihn foltern und das
herauszufinden amerikanische regierung
und witali aussagen auf jeden fall auf
jeden fall die amerikanische regierung
wahrscheinlich die ut tahrir mindestens
er oder sie neigt dazu ja zu sagen weil
man obwohl man sehr ist viel schmerz
hier produziert trotzdem kann man noch
mehr und nutzen oder schmerz vermeiden
dadurch dass die bomben explodiert
während andere wären handel der ethiker
sorgen würden dass man wollte zum
beispiel sozusagen eine rote linie ist
und das müssen wir nicht näher
betrachten dieses problem aber man kann
es sofort sehen warum dieses problem
oder vielleicht diese schwäche von
terrorismus wenn das eigentlich erst wie
wieso das auf tiere offenbar ist weil da
müssen wir nur überlegen zum beispiel
sollen wir die experimente durchführen
wahrscheinlich ja also wir quälen
vielleicht mehrere tausend häuser
aber dadurch hätten wir das leben von
mehreren hunderttausend von menschen und
menschen sind sowieso komplexe und
können komplexe der erfahrungen machen
als tiere also die die mäuse sind
praktisch pro maus weniger wert als ein
mensch ist pro mensch oder vielleicht
sind die paar lebenserfahrungen von
menschen mehr wert als die
lebenserfahrungen von mäusen um das meer
wie sänger auszudrücken
also man hätte sofort vielleicht eine
begründung warum man in manchen fällen
tiere halten können
und da ist mögen marke theoretiker
natürlich nichts
trotzdem ist es nicht der fall dass der
täter sofort hier zu geben muss und
einknicken muss sänger ist er dafür
bekannt dass sie tätig sehr sehr
ernsthaft betreibt und er würde die
normalerweise funktionieren so zeigen
dass man auf gut und realistisch
überlegen als gute touristische
überlegungen zeigen kann warum man
fassen die tiere mit ihren
experimentieren würden und so würde und
so weiter und so fort werden weil das
ist ein problem mit tele tallis muss ist
dass man die interessen von tieren in
marken von opfern würde
kritiker wollen das nicht genau wie
manche können nicht die interessen von
menschen in hopfen waren haben wir das
problem mit teller tourismus ist aus der
theoretischen perspektive mindestens ist
der so genannte phänomen von freeridern
freeriding glaub ich ist würde
vielleicht sogar als deutsche deutsche
ausdruck eingedeutscht weil es nicht
aber freeriding heißt zum beispiel
natürlich wollen wir klimawandel stoppen
aber es ist egal ob ich zum beispiel
flug mit flugzeug fliege weil darauf
kommt es nicht an
nein natürlich wenn alle aufhören würden
zu fliegen würde das gerne einen
erheblichen unterschied machen aber es
ist wirklich egal ob ich damit aufhöre
also ich bin nur ich bin nur ein mensch
und ich kann nicht so viel bewirken
durch mein engagement und vielleicht
sogar könnte man sagen selbst wenn ich
mein ganzes leben damit verbringen würde
umwelt sachen
und hier schützen die grüne partei bla
bla bla bla
das bringt auch nicht so viel und ich
habe nur mein mein leben
also anstatt dieses 0,00 0 001 prozent
hilfe anzubieten soll ich einfach leben
mein gott ja oder nein wieso haben wir
die lichter hier an weil es schließlich
egal ist also china wirft unmengen von
von stoffen sind das alles egal yahav
einzelne wovon einzeln menschen ist egal
das ist das programm von freeriding also
das heißt ich weiß dass das was ich
mache schlagt es wenn alle das machen
aber das ist egal war dass sowieso
machen
also wieso soll ich das nicht auch
machen ja hier ist und hier und
vielleicht noch nicht ganz klar warum
das solarium
ein problem ist aber betrachten sie ist
es so wenn wir wenig weh getan ist zum
beispiel werde weil ich mit alitalia bin
dann muss ich wirklich überlegen wie
viel wird das bringen
also was wieviel day tut es der
fleischindustrie dass ich und nur ich
vegetarisch bleibe eigentlich nichts
das werden sie buchstäblich nicht merken
also es nicht als ob die leute die in
den in der in den gremium von der
fleischindustrie böse fleisch dass sie
alle da sitzen draußen ist vegetarier
geworden da müssen wir weniger tiere
dieses jahr schlachten weil er so viel
fleisch ist und vielleicht bin ich ein
schlechtes beispiel
aber eben diesen nicht als ob sie darauf
achten was einzelne menschen machen und
deswegen könnte man wirklich
wahrscheinlich kam buchstäblich sagen es
ist unsolidarisch gesehen egal ob ich
vegetarisch labour oder nichts das
könnte meine technik bestreiten
das wäre empirisch zu überlegen aber
selbst wenn es nicht egal ist
vielleicht tut das ein bisschen was ja
aber dann müsste man dagegen mit
sozusagen in der waage setzen wie wie
unangenehm und umständlich ist es für
mich vegetarisch lebenden mann
vielleicht überwiegt mein leiden
das nutzen von vegetarisch leben wenn
wir zurück so wieder der frage wenn ich
nicht bald also das ist auch ein problem
für italien und aus diesen gründen gibt
es auch leute die ard unter logisch
denken wollen
das heißt dass sie diese rote linien
haben wollen
genau wie man menschen nie foltert soll
man irgendwas den tieren nie antun
einfach weil es unzulässig ist es stoß
gegen eine 1 hält eine ethische regelung
die in stein gemeißelt ist also hier
sind wir nicht bei mir sondern ist der
vater dieser politik natürlich immer nur
kant theologie aus dem griechen für das
was man machen muss habe ich heute auf
einem handy gesehen was meine tochter in
glauzig religionsunterricht bekommen hat
die anthologie hat mitunter
dachte ich dass er wenig in der
vorlesung heute also hier geht es nicht
darum irgend was zu kalkulieren oder
maximieren minimieren das ist alles so
das merken wir alles aus dem fenster
hier erstellen wir was die ethische
regeln sind also ich würde sagen gesetze
das können wir durch irgendein das
können wir irgendwie erreichen dadurch
dass wir uns auf vernunft einsetzen und
sehen welche gesetze rationell pflichtig
sind für uns und dann sollen wir unsere
pflicht erfüllen
ok natürlich ist dann eine offene frage
was sind unsere fläche in sich denn
tieren und hier haben manche philosophen
versucht wirklich saison genau wie wir
eine theorie der menschenrechte haben
sie haben versucht eine theorie der
tiere rechten auszustatten zum beispiel
tom regen ist ein gutes beispiel dafür
und das ist genau obwohl sr diener die
wollen natürlich eigentlich die gleiche
ziele erreichen wie die tiere titel
italia haben sie eine entgegengesetzte
theorie wie man das macht weil hier geht
es nicht um wie gesagt nicht um nutzen
oder lust zu wachsen nehmen oder
umnutzen und schmerzen leiden zu
minimieren
hier geht es darum zu sagen dass tiere
auch rechte haben also nicht nur
interessen sondern auch rechte an hand
diesen dieser interessen und da könnte
man vielleicht sogar sogar weitergehen
hinrichtung
hier hört sanfte behandlung gehen als
digital ed arie gehen können weil da
könnte man sagen hier als selbst wenn es
sehr viel bringen würde zum beispiel mit
zehn häuser experiment durchzuführen was
krebs dann hals am ende selbst dann darf
man das nicht machen weil die mäuse auch
rechte haben und du würdest nichts ein
mensch mit einem mensch so
experimentieren und genau so sollst du
nicht mit neues experten
experimentieren die wollen auch
ausschließen dass man einen mann oder
frau also ein mensch so zum beispiel 50
mal so viel wert kalkuliert als einem
haus wurde also ein mensch ist 755 mäuse
oder so weil sie komplexe erfahrungen
haben oder sollte also das wird für sie
ein fehler an der stelle touristischen
methode
besprechen sie manchmal beispiel wie
würde man 1000 hunde opfern um einen
mensch zu retten zum beispiel nehmen wir
an es gibt zwei boote werden beide
versenken wir können nur ein boot
bleiben auf einem boot sind 1100 auf dem
anderen boot ist ein mensch was würden
wir machen ja und wenn sie da nicht
sicher sind dann 1 million und ein
mensch zehn millionen hunde ein mensch
und sie sehen es irgendwie lächerlich
und sie sehen wird wahrscheinlich auch
dass solche fragen eigentlich nichts es
ist nicht so offensichtlich dass wir
solche fragen beantworten können
das wirkt alles gegen twitter ist auch
hier wurden schon methoden der
politischen floss die eingesetzt um
diese probleme heranzugehen und da ist
ein prominentes beispiel natürlich die
politische theorie von john rawls lange
geschichte aber kurzum hat john rawls
versucht politische liberalismus da du
hast du begründen dass er unter anderem
ein gedankenexperiment vorschlägt das
heißt das schleier des unwissens das
kennen sie wahrscheinlich alle also wenn
wir überlegen was ist ein gutes sogar
politisches system
wir sollten uns vorstellen dass wir vor
unserem geburtstagen nichts wissen
wo wir in die gesellschaft sind also für
man oder frau welche hautfarbe wie reich
und so weiter also wir haben keine
ahnung unter welchen bedingungen wir
geboren werden und dann sollen wir die
gesellschaft so gestalten dass wir die
beste chancen haben mit dem ergebnis
zufrieden zu sein und er argumentiert
deswegen dafür dass man konnte diesen
bedingungen nie arrangieren würde dass
manche einfach durch pech total an und
diskriminiert werden wie es zb in der
usa der fall ist
man würde vielmehr schauen dass das alle
die gleiche rechte haben die gleiche
chancen haben glücklich zu werden und so
weiter also all die klassische
prinzipien von liberalismus
okay das ist auch die kleine einfach
eine kleine erklärung von haus
diese diese methode kann man auch bei
tieren einsetzen weil stand sie jetzt
nicht vor dass sie als mensch in eine
gesellschaft geboren werden stellen sie
sich vor sie wären als lebewesen in
diese gesellschaft geboren
was wollen sie dass die regeln zur
lebewesen in dieser gesellschaft sind
wollen sie dass wenn sie kühe oder
hängen oder was wenn man geboren sind
geschlachtet werden wahrscheinlich nicht
also wenn sie nicht wissen ob sie mensch
oder kühl werden dann ist plötzlich sehr
interessant zu wissen dass es den kühen
gut geht also genau dort genau diese art
von argument kann man dann auch
tierethik begründet das so sagen dass
deswegen habe ich vorhergesagt dass
tätig und kritische flosse wie eng
verbunden ist wenn man sieht dass die
bahn die frage der tiere behandlung
eigentlich eine fassung ist von
weiterverbreiten fragen über politische
floss
dann nur kurz versprochen dass ich etwas
für die andere seite sage also was was
könnte man sozusagen gegen tätig sagen
oder was könnte man sagen um die jetzige
situation dort hinein in unsere
gesellschaft zu begründen
und hier ist das hauptargument glaube
ich dass wir zwischen menschen und
tieren ein nicht nur einen unterschied
haben sondern einen sehr wichtigen
unmoralisch und entscheidenden
unterschied haben nämlich menschen sind
personen und tiere sind keine personen
jetzt wollen sie wissen was es eine
person antwort schwer zu sagen natürlich
aber zum beispiel vielleicht heißt dass
ein wesen das wasser bewusst ist was
marie theres sind was pläne für die
zukunft machen kann was irgendwie
komplexe hinterlassen hat was zb eine
native geschichte über sein eigenes
leben erzählen kann und so weiter und so
fort an also ein interessantes leben
führen kann
und das so margit theoretiker können
menschen schauen und hier nichts
natürlich ist es sehr sehr schwierige
sache so definieren was person heißt
aber was auch immer es heißt könnten wir
behaupten ist es plausibel dass nur
menschen und lebewesen personen sind und
nur personen haben moralischen wert wenn
das der fall ist können wir vielleicht
dann dadurch begründen warum wird ihre
so behandeln wie wir es tun und wie sie
sehen werden ist es auch in der
geschichte der fluss wieder fall dass
man sehr oft die werte der tiere im
winter tat dadurch dass man behauptet
hat dass sie irgendwie nicht personen
sind
zum beispiel dass sie nicht vernünftig
sind okay sie hat meine frage
[Musik]
jetzt müssen
ist frei
ich esse in der woche durchschnittlich
sagen
man merkt sie ausgleich
das ist schon in der tat viel glück ja
[Musik]
ja ja ja dass man könnte vielleicht
sogar sagen das ist eine empirische
kommen philosophische frage was man
machen darf
und theoretisch mindestens könnte man
das kalkulieren aber ich bin zu dem
ergebnis komme gekommen
ich kann 100 gramm fleisch weder woche
essen dann bin ich irgendwann ich ein
b200 erst dann wenn ich irgendwie falsch
gegangen ja genau
das klingt ein bisschen lächerlich
natürlich und genau deswegen dass manche
tierethik diese ganze herangehensweise
falschen wir haben andere
so haben wir sehen ganz mensch reagieren
mit wasser wurde aber auch nicht
ja ich meine es gibt sicherlich
überlegungen erstens die frage wieso
sollen wir vermeiden tierarten zu
vernichten
ja und es gibt auch in meinem und auch
gibt es vielleicht mehr das was sie
fragen
denn wenn es wenn es wirklich so
entscheidendes dass menschen personen
sind und tiere keine personen dann gibt
es diese sogenannten oasis also
grenzfälle die irgendwie zwischen
menschen und tiere sind zb machen
scheinen fast menschlich zu sein also
jetzt gibt natürlich affen die viel
praktischer sind als manche menschen
ohne beispiele zu benennen haben dann
gibt es menschliche grenzfälle wie zum
beispiel leute die mit geburt defekte
geboren werden und so dass das
schwierige fälle für alle die in dieser
debatte dann involviert sind haben weil
die tiere die also fast alle wollen
irgendwie zu dem ergebnis kommen dass
auch wenn tiere rechte und so weiter
haben dass menschen mehrwert haben als
tiere weil das zu vereinen ist für die
meisten sehr konto an tui tief meinen
nichts menschen im allgemeinen tier den
allgemeinen sondern ein mensch ein tier
ein philosoph der sagen würde opfer den
mensch anstatt das tier war es egal oder
weil das tier mehrwert hat das würde die
meisten leute würden die meisten leute
im klausi befinden also das wollen sie
normalerweise vermeiden und dann die
haben sie das problem haben gibt es
nicht manche tiere die komplexe
fortschritten mehr bewusst sind als
manche menschen
das ist ein problem an ein anderes
problem ist ist auf der anderen seite
die leute die eben sagen wann es gibt
eine eine große lücke zwischen menschen
und tiere und das ist moralisch
entscheidend die müssen dann
wieso diese grenzfälle die lücke nicht
schließen
sozusagen war dann ist sehr unscharf
also was ist eine person was nicht
wir werden dieses albums
ja das ist genau das problem dass sie
habt ihr hättet seite haben also wenn
wir oder ich vielleicht das allgemeine
problem zu erklären warum wir das nicht
machen dürfen
das ist noch also noch mal sind wir
zurück bei der frage wenn es wirklich
der fall wenn man es gibt manche tiere
die man einfach mehr in allen hinsichten
machen können und erleben als marke
menschen und der deswegen scheint es
dass wir beide tiere wären die sind wir
bei der annahme dass einfach spezies
[Musik]
also die die frage welche spezies mann
hat also spezies mitgliederschaft
vielleicht könnte man sagen jetzt
irgendwie moralisch entscheidende frage
ist warum
und das ist ein problem für die leute
die speziesismus eingreifen wollen und
ein problem für die leute die das
verteidigen
so nun sagen der mensch ist halt
insofern mehr wert weil im christlichen
sinne als auch bewährtes geschaffen
worden ist
das tier ist nicht ab wird gott ist
deswegen hört sich das becken
ja das habe ich nicht betrachtet weil
habe andererseits werden wir im laufe
dieser vorlesungsreihe werden wir
natürlich diese begründungen sehen zb
also ein beispiel ist dass man tiere gut
behandeln soll wie bei sie uns
unterworfen sind genau wie wir gott
unterworfen sind und gott und mit gott
behandelt uns gut ist gnädig zu uns und
wir sollen genauso die den tieren ginge
also das kann man so oder so ein wenden
könnten
letzte frage mich dann weitergehen eine
interessante frage die ich ja wenn worte
danke hier ist ob es eine weitere
ethische frage ob tiere auch moralisch
verantwortlich sein können und
interessant ist dass mir ich glaube wir
es irgendwie neigen wir alle dazu zu
denken dass man jetzt ist er zum
beispiel affen moralische bedeuteten
moralisch bedeutend sind also würden sie
nicht einfach alles an tun als ob sie
steine werden anderes da ist neigen wir
wahrscheinlich alle die zu bedenken dass
tiere keine moralische morales handelnde
thesen sind also sie können nicht wohl
alle schlecht oder gut seien die legen
nur zum beispiel wenn sie sich
gegenseitig belasten und das ist
interessant weil zum beispiel kant als
sie hat die moralische werte von
menschen sehr eng mit der tatsache
knüpft das menschen moralisch handeln
und wenn rentiere moralisches wert haben
aber nicht moralisch handeln können dann
bleibt das bricht das auseinander
das ist eine interessante frage jetzt
soll ich schnell was zur philosophie des
geistes zu haben sagen und dann
abschließend nur ein bisschen warum
warum ich es spannend finde
das alles historisch sie behandeln und
zum glück muss man nicht so viel sagen
haben
erstens wird was man irgendwie
offensichtlich aber ich will das gesagt
haben nein zu sagen vorteil was wir
haben über haben die phasen der
geschichte der profi ist dass wir
einfach empirisch gesehen viel viel mehr
über tiere wissen als zum beispiel der
kreis oder thomas von aquin oder habe
seiner mutter konfuzius oder platon also
man kann vielleicht heutzutage sagen
dass wir sehr gute empirische belege
haben um die frage zu beantworten
genau wie die vielen tiere mit uns
gemeinsam haben oder wir können
mindestens behaupten dass wir in einer
besseren lage sind diese frage zu
beantworten
als wir jemals vorher waren trotzdem ist
es das mindeste zu sagen nicht leicht
einfach das was wir über die geister
dafür der menschen sagen auf tiere
übertragen
vielmehr haben wir empirische befunde
diese abweichen sind bei verschiedenen
tierarten also noch mal ein beispiel von
dem was ich vorher gesagt habe dass wir
all diese fragen nicht pauschal für alle
nichtmenschliche tiere beantworten
können
also erstens dass und zweitens haben wir
in der villa für das video des geistes
eine grundlegende frage vielleicht sogar
ein unlösbares rätsel dass es nie
möglich ist zu wissen genau wie es erst
ein anderes wesen zu sein
es gibt einen berühmten aufsatz das habe
ich auf alles ab hochgeladen
von thomas niggl dh und bei hat diese
dieses beispiel die fledermaus genommen
weil haben fledermäuse mit dieser so nah
mit diesem sommer gerät dann navigieren
können ja und er seine behauptung ist
dass wir uns einfach schlicht nicht
vorstellen können wie das ist
und da das voltaire bestimmte folgen
dann erschließen für die philosophie des
geistes nämlich dass es irgendwelche
subjektive phänomene geben muss die man
selber erfahren muss um sie zu verstehen
das könnte man vielleicht mit dem
berühmten beispiel vergleichen wo eine
frau in einem schwarz weiß zimmer
aufwächst und dann farben erforscht und
alles alle wissenschaftliche tatsachen
zur farbe lernt und dann als die 21 wird
sieht sie eine rote blume und die
behauptung ist dass sie etwas neues
lernt was sie weiß alles was es gibt
über farben aber nicht wie roth
ausschaut
und das heißt dass es irgendwas
subjektives wie irgendwas qualitatives
gibt die man zusagen von innen erfahren
muss das würde heißen dass das mental
leben nicht ausschließlich empirisch
beschreibbar ist also dass das war ein
eckpunkt so wie ich das verstanden habe
aber ich wo davon wollte ich nur den
schluss entnehmen dass es im allgemeinen
sehr schwierig ist vielleicht so waren
möglich wirklich zu wissen ist wie es
ist eine böse sein oder vielleicht sogar
ein anderer mensch und da kommt haut
dazu die so genannt haben
weiter mainz also ob man die man wissen
kann dass andere menschen sogar wirklich
ein mentales leben haben wie wir
weil man keinen zugang darauf hat und
man kann sie sich vor ich könnte mir
vorstellen
sie sind alle roboter und läuft nichts
ab in ihrem geist
ich bin der einzige hier der tatsächlich
erfahrungen bewusstsein habe man sie
sind alle automaten
das klingt ein bisschen lächerlich
und das würde heißen dass diese
vorlesung der krieg zeitverschwendung
war also ich hoffe dass sich der fall
ist aber ist so lächerlich wie das
klingt das ist genau was die kartelle
gesagt hat die die tun so als ob sie ein
mentales leben haben haben sie aber
nicht und die frage ist deswegen wie wir
überhaupt zeigen könnten dass tiere ein
erfahrungen haben dass die mentales
leben genießen
sozusagen ein anderes eine und und hier
gibt könnte man das war allgemeinen und
sagen nicht nur bei bewusstsein oder
mentales leben sondern bei jeder
kognitive fähigkeit könnte man sagen
naja man also ich soll noch mal auf
nummer sicher gehen und wenn ich eine
bestimmte art von haltung oder fähigkeit
bei tieren beobachte ich so nie einfach
sagen das tier ist genau wie ein mensch
zum beispiel das tier kann hahn pläne
machen wie das tier auf seine mutter
kommt ja oder kann haben kann sich daran
erinnern wo es sein futter liegt usw
dann denken hat genau wie hier
und vielleicht denkt wo es - hinten im
garten ja zb habe eine schöne anekdote
gelesen über einen hafen wo sie sie
haben einen jungen affen in einer gruppe
von affen durch ein fenster zu schauen
laut während essen in der erde begraben
würde und dann haben sie das ganz dazu
gemacht und dann nach zehn minuten haben
sie alle hafen rausgelassen in diesem
hof wurde das essen bekam war und dieser
harfe ein junger harfe ist einfach also
sehr sehr gezielt diese stelle vorbei
gegangen als ob nichts wahr und hat
gewartet bis die ältere stärkere affen
abgelenkt waren und dann ist er hat ist
er hingelaufen hat das aus gekommen
geflossen
und jetzt natürlich könnte man sagen
okay dass das muss heißen das ist also
er hat so genauso getan wie wir es
machen würden hat überlegt was soll ich
machen oder aber man könnte vielleicht
haben dagegen einwenden ist natürlich
nicht der fall dass ameisen komplexe
pläne haben in ihrem kopf leihen wie sie
dieses ganze system in dem nest dann
zustande bringen das machen sie alles
aus instinkt und was wir im allgemeinen
machen sollen jetzt immer vorsichtig
sein und nur die fähigkeiten den tieren
zu schreiben die wir zu schreiben müssen
also wir sind sozusagen davon ausgehen
dass sie dass sie zu hause tot sind dass
sie die automaten sind aus dass wir das
nicht vermeiden können und bei dem hafen
ist es sehr schwer zu
diese diese haltung zu erklären ohne
irgendwelche mentale überlegung zu
schreiben
aber wenn wir es wenn wir auskommen
können ohne solche mentale überlegungen
zu schreiben sollten wir das tun und das
ist eine regelung die von einem
wissenschaftler aus dem 19 jahrhundert
namens bakonyi ist so geschrieben ist
oder oerlikon heute morgen heißt er also
morgen mit nachname dass das war ein
wissenschaftler der der genau dieses
vorgehen vorgeschlagen hat also immer
sozusagen konservativ vorgehen und nur
die fähigkeiten den tieren zu schreiben
die man zu schreiben muss und in diesem
buch das ich kann also rumgehen lassen
habe
gibt es einen interessanten absatz von
herrn stuhl wo sie argumentiert dass das
falsch ist
es ist sozusagen zu konservativ weil man
genauso gut argumentieren können könnte
dass man immer die höchste fähigkeit zu
schreiben soll
die die haltung erklärt und die sollen
wir immer die niedrigere fähigkeit zu
schreiben als die hürde zum beispiel
instinkt anstatt erinnerung oder sowas
bei mäuse oder ameisen oder wasser
gelangen und was sie deswegen sagt ist
dass man einfach empirische beweise
sammeln soll
auf beiden seiten und versuchen
experimente durchzuführen die das
entscheiden erinnerung oder instinkt und
wenn man nicht durch empirische beweise
entscheiden kann ob jetzt hat die tiere
das durch instinkt oder erinnerung
machen zb soll man neutral und
agnostisch bleiben
was bleibe ich sehr überzeugen wirst
also man sieht im allgemeinen dass es
sehr schwierig ist solche fragen zu
beantworten sie genau welche mentalen
fähigkeiten tiere einsetzen können
gerade weil eine bestimmte haltung oft
mit verschiedenen möglichen fähigkeiten
kompatibel ist und jetzt sehr schnell
und blüten würde ich nur abschließend
sagen warum ich jetzt interessant finde
diese fragen historisch zu betrachten
[Musik]
erstens können hier würde ich sagen es
gibt wie immer wenn man betrachtet die
frage die frage bis heute in die
vereinsgeschichte dafür ist wie
interessant es gibt immer die antwort
weil es geschichtlich interessante und
die antwort weil es für mich interessant
ist also geschichtlich würde ich sagen
dass wir eine so viele theorien aus der
vergangenheit besser verstehen
dadurch dass wir diese
dass wir uns auf dieses thema
fokussieren was man sehr selten macht
also man man das ist irgendwie allgemein
bekannt dass wir jetzt hier tätig machen
dass tiere untersucht werden und dass
wir mit ihren experimentieren um sachen
unser geist heraus zu finden also dass
das heutzutage stattfindet sehen wie
klar
aber leider ist es irgendwie eine
allgemeine annahme dass philosophen in
der vergangenheit sich kaum mit tieren
beschäftigt haben und wenn sie das
gemacht haben war das sehr deprimierend
wie zum beispiel descartes aber wir
werden aber zeigen dass in verschiedenen
kulturen das nicht der fall war
also ich es ist erstaunlich wie
ernsthaft philosophen aus griechenland
islam china indien und so weiter und so
fort die in allen diesen kulturen haben
philosophen sich mit tiere beschäftigt
dass er ernsthaft also das ist
interessant und dadurch gewinnt man auch
eine perspektive auf die philosophische
anthropologie weil man die theorie dass
der menschheit oft dadurch bespricht
dass man menschen mädchen vergleicht und
deswegen ist es so dass wenn sie
menschen gesprochen
besprechen sie auch tiere als gegenpart
oder eben umgekehrt also ist wirklich
sehr eine sehr reiche ein servicebereich
für die geschichte philosophie und
deswegen historisch sehr interessant und
spannend und ich hoffe dass jetzt das
sagen kann
andererseits wenn man kein eigenes keine
historische hinterlassen hat was schade
erinnert werden natürlich aber selbst
wenn man sich nur für diese abstrakte
fragen hat interessiert ist die
geschichte wie hier auch sehr
interessant aus mehreren gründen
man könnte vielleicht meinen das ist
nicht so interessant ist genau wie das
was ich vorher gesagt habe dass unser
empirische theorien über tiere jetzt
heutzutage viel besser sind
also wir kennen uns einfach viel besser
aus mit ihren als wir damals zu
handhaben und das stimmt natürlich
allerdings haben wir mehrere sachen in
der geschichte plus wie die wirklich
aufschlussreich sind erstens sind wir
sozusagen nichts in unserer jetzigen
philosophischen anthropologie befangen
wenn wir aus der perspektive von antiken
indien oder griechenland oder china zum
beispiel denken haben wir ganz andere
möglichkeiten
anfragen über menschen zu betrachten und
auflagen über tiere zum beispiel wie wir
senden sind gibt es theorien der
tierethik in indien oder es nahmen die
wir heutzutage gar nicht haben
die ich gängig sind weil die prinzipien
dieser ethischen theorien völlig anders
sind also die kommen aus einer ganz
anderen perspektive und durch diese
perspektive kommen sie zu dem ergebnis
dass für tiere besser behandeln sollen
und das ist interessant zu sehen wie
weit wir vorher gesagt habe was die
theoretiker machen wollen heutzutage ist
aus so viele mögliche blickwinkel wie
möglich zu dem ergebnis kommen dass wir
tiere besser behandelt worden und diese
ältere blickwinkeln zu sein denn oft
außer acht gelassen
also das ist interessant und was auch
interessant ist glaube ich ist dass man
nicht paar in der geschichte der
philosophie oft die andere seite sieht
weil so viele antike mit lieblose
wirklich davon ausgegangen sind dass wir
genau das macht mit tieren machen können
was wir wollen
so hat man damals gemacht und ab und zu
haben sich überlegt ja wieso ist das
also wieso ist das in ordnung zu sein
oder was ist unser verhältnis zu tieren
überhaupt und als sie das erklärt haben
haben sie philosophische begründungen
gegeben wie so wird ihre ausnutzen
können schlachten dürfen essen dürfen
usw also in dieser vorlesungen in diesen
vorlesungen werden wir philosophische
begründungen haben gegen die die
theoretiker eigentlich argumentieren
müssen
und vielleicht haben wir sogar die
wurzel der eigentlichen jetzigen
gesellschaftlichen einstellungen tiere
gegenüber und das zu verstehen ist
natürlich auch wichtig für leute die
sich für tiere verstehen also ich freue
mich darauf ich hoffe sie auch und dann
sehen wir uns nächste woche in wir haben
in der ersten in der nächsten sitzung
das thema ist bösartig und platon wie
gesagt es gibt schon lesungen besser